>>Male Presenter: Okay folks welcome to today's
Authors @ Google session where we've got Alex
Bellos who's going to tell us about some Adventures
in Numberland. So it's really great to have
you here Alex.
Little bit of an intro: Alex studied mathematics
and philosophy at university but he started
his career as a journalist. And I read with
great interest in the intro to the book, so
eventually moving to Rio as the Guardian's
South American correspondent and he's since
presented a five-part series on Brazil for
the BBC called Inside Out Brazil, and his
short films about the Amazon have been broadcast
on the BBC and lots of other channels like
More 4and Al Jazeera. He's written other books,
and one of these I was particularly excited
about, so he's written a book called Futebol,the
Brazilian Way of Life, and the one I was particularly
excited about ghost written Pelé, The Autobiography.
And today he's gonna tell us about some of
the ideas in his latest book Alex's Adventures
in Numberland which you all have a copy of.
So Alex it's great to have you here and I'll
hand over to you.
Alex Bellos: Thank you it's great to be here
in --
[applause]
in Sir James park near Victoria. See I'm Alex
Bellos and I write about maths. And not a
lot of people write about maths 'cause I think
right from kind of school age we're sort of
divided into people who are kind of the maths
numbers people and the words kind of literature
people. And I think that's a false dichotomy
and I think that we need to be much more aware
of the fact that sort of maths and science
is actually part of our cultural heritage
just as well, just as much as our scientific
heritage.
And in this spirit, here's a conundrum for
you, which links both numbers and words and
it is: if all numbers were listed alphabetically,
what number would come second? Now normally
I'm at literary festivals talking to kind
of literary folk and they never get it. It's
actually quite simple and for you guys to
be here you probably had to do this famous
kind of Google questions which are really
difficult. So this far too easy so I'm gonna
add an extra thing. I want the answer in French.
[chuckles] So I'll get the answer at end of
the talk.
Now I qualified as a journalist but before
that I was a mathematician. So when I came
to write about maths I started to write about
it as a journalist, so really as if I was
a foreign correspondent in the world of numbers.
And being this foreign correspondent, I traveled
sort of back in time to tell the history of
maths. I also made geographical journeys,
so I went all around the world and I spent
a year or so going around the world and I
went to Japan, which we'll get into later,
I went to India, I went to France, went to
Germany, always trying to meet people whose
lives bring out maths in some interesting
way.
I went twice to the States but I went across
the West Coast, the Midwest, I went to the
East Coast.
For instance I went to St. Louis, Missouri
to meet the president of the American Dozenal
Society who's campaigning to introduce two
new digits to our 10 digit system, decimal
obviously, so you would count one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, dek which
is a single digit, el which is a single digit,
and then dough which would be one zero. And
that was interesting and he actually uses
that in his work doing architectural drawings.
So obviously if you go up to 12 you can divide
into 3 and 4 much easier than you can if you're
decimal.
I also went to Reno, Nevada to meet the man
who sets the odds for most of the world's
slot machines, 'cause most of the world's
slot machines come from one company based
in Reno and there's a chief mathematician
there whose job it is to make sure that all
the maths is correct. And so that's a great
way of kind of bringing why maths is relevant
and also the history of probability really
begins with gambling so it's interesting to
go and speak to someone who is on the kind
of cutting edge of gambling.
And also I went to Scottsdale, Arizona to
meet Jerome Carter. And the reason I went
to meet him is that he is a modern day Pythagorean.
And Pythagoras is the most famous name in
maths. Pythagoras is also the oldest real
person, as in Adam and Eve didn't exist or
just ideas that maybe they did, but the person
who we learned at school who's the oldest
living person we know definitely existed is
Pythagoras. And this is kind of interesting
because surely the oldest living person we
should be studying maybe in history, but no.
Pythagoras is really before anyone we really
learn in history.
Pythagoras is famous in maths for the theorem
that bears his name, the square of a, for
right angle triangles the square of the hypotheses
is equal to square of the other two sides.
Turns out Pythagoras probably didn't invent
this, certainly is was known before him and
the earliest proofs come from China.
[pause]
Also if you kind of look into what he was
and what he did it's a fascinating story that
he's a little bit like kind of Jesus in the
sense that he was a spiritual and religious
leader who didn't run anything himself but
over the following centuries had lots and
lots of people write about them and kind of
raise them to this sort almost divine figure.
And that's essentially why several hundred
years after he died he was sort of most attributed
the Pythagorean Theorem because he was the
guy who kind of made maths mystical.
And that's what I find fascinating when I
was researching Pythagoras is that he's both
the earliest name in maths and responsible
for maths, but really what he did was he invented
anti-maths 'cause he thought that numbers
were not just numbers, did not just represent
quantifies but also represented qualities.
So two was feminine, three was masculine,
and five was the union of them both so the
most spiritual number.
And this mysticism that we really can sort
of date back to Pythagoras as influential
as his sort of mathematical legacy. So and
also sort of Gematria which came afterwards,
the Masons all kind of has this sort of Pythagorean
basis. In fact the Masons is essentially modeled
on the Pythagorean Brotherhood which was this
sort of cult like group where Pythagoras lived.
So the reason why went to see Jerome is that
he is a numerologist. You go to him, you pay
lots of, thousands of dollars and you tell
him what you're called, you give him your
date of birth, and he will advise you based
on the numbers. And I don't believe anything
he really said apart from one thing which
was, "Most fortune tellers are poor, that
makes no sense."
[laughter]
Which is true [chuckles] and he's not poor
and he gets money from being the sort of number
clairvoyant. So he said that he advised Puff
Daddy to become P. Diddy and then just become
Diddy and he was paid thousands for that.
He also advised people like Mike Tyson, Jay-Z,
and he has spent all his money on motorbikes
and has this kind of trophy wife, this sort
of amazing condo.
And I thought, "Well if this was expensive
maybe I could get some advice it'd be pretty
good." So I said, "Okay I'm called Alex Bellos,
good name bad name?" And he said, "Well what's
your real name on your birth certificate?"
I said, "Well it's actually Alexander." And
he went, "Hum. You might be quite successful
as Alex but not half as successful as you
will be if you change your name to Alexander."
I said, "Why?" And he said, "Come on, one
of the greatest men in the history of civilization
was not called Alex the Great."
[laughter]
And so I thought that's not a mathematical
reason and then he actually showed me, he
wrote down all the numbers and R is a very
good letter to end a name with and X is a
terrible name to end a name with. So I actually
thought in my book about maybe changing my
name to Alexander Bellos, but then actually
people might start to think that I actually
believe in this and I have been criticized
for sort of giving people like this too much
space in the book. But actually I think all,
anything that encourages us to think about
numbers in any way at all is all good.
[pause]
Numerology talks about magic numbers and spiritual
numbers and lucky numbers. Three especially,
three is the magic number. Now three is a
magic number, three is very special and if
you think about it, why do we always want
to know the top three? And why in the pageant
places are there just three? Why not the name
of the top two or the top four? Just so you
know you're in the school playground you don't
say, "What are your nine favorite bands?"
It's either gonna be top 3, top 5, top 10,
top 100. It's obvious why 100, 10, and 5 are
numbers that we like to round up to because
it makes anatomical sense. But why three?
Well three is the largest number, it's the
largest grouping that we can understand without
thinking. And this leads on to the science
of numerical cognition which is essentially
the science of staring at dots and working
out how long it takes you to work out how
many numbers of dots. So the simplest experiment
numerical commission which has been done for
decades is just this: I show a dot to someone
who's wired up to like a timer and I say,
"How many dots?" And the person will say,
"One." Instantly you say one, instantly you
say two, instantly you say three, you don't
instantly say four there's a little delay
and it goes on and that's like 25, you'd never
get that instantly.
[laughter]
But the moment that you start to actually
have to count rather than something where
it is subitized is four. So why is this interesting?
It's interesting culturally.
So this is contemporary Chinese, ancient India,
and ancient Rome. Because one, two, and three
we instantly see without counting it's one,
two, or three they're perfectly good as symbols.
Whereas because four, we have to count them,
it's a terrible symbol. So there are other
symbols and this is, I've just chosen three
but there are other, writing isn't the word,
it's exactly the same.
Now I was giving this talk once in this sort
of grand kind of room and there was a great
antique clock like right there and it was
in Roman numerals and as I looked up I thought,
"The four was IIII," just completely contradicting
what I was saying. But actually I kind of
knew that and the Romans did, sometimes, put
IIII on their clocks because position tells
you what time it is you don't actually need
to read the number and that would be for aesthetic
reasons. And whereas at the beginning of Rome
they did use IIII, towards the end of the
Roman Empire it was always IV.
Now let's look back at India. So about one
and half thousand years ago in some parts
of India this is the symbols for one, two,
three, and four. And just imagine you are
writing that without taking your pen or whatever
they used in ancient India off the paper you
get that which is the origin of the digits
we use today. So even though we call them
Arabic numerals they actually got to the Arab
lands from India. We should call them Hindo-numeric
numerals.
But the reason why we use Hindo-numeric numerals,
why that we use the system that came from
India isn't because of this sort of funny
little trick, it's because of the number zero.
So the joke is, "What did India give the world?
Nothing." Well,
[laughter]
actually giving the world nothing, the mathematical
zero, was probably the greatest conceptually
possibly in all of mathematics. It permitted
arithmetic to be done by sort of the common
man, it really meant that quantitative science
could begin. And actually it made sort of
arithmetic and numbers really be part of maths
because the Greeks didn't have the zero so
basically Greek mathematics it's just, it's
all visual, it's all geometric.
So being a journalist I thought zero came
from India I need to go to India to try and
find out why, one and a half thousand years
too late. So I went to meet this guy here
who is the Shankaracharya of Puri who is one
of the most spiritual men in India; one of
four Shankaracharyas he has a temple one in
each of the north, south, east, and west,
his is in the east and millions and millions
of people follow him.
And it was quite difficult to get an interview
with him to talk about numbers and maths.
He actually has published some books on maths
and numbers. But when I did it was fascinating
so I went there to Puri in the Bay of Bengal
and was told because you're going to meet
him in a spiritual place you can't speak English
to him you can only comm, he can't communicate
in anything but Hindi even though he speaks
fluent English." So I had to go, which is
quite a good trick. So I had to go and speak
to the disciple in English, then he would
translate it into Hindi, then it would come
back then come back to me.
So this is, it's kind of like Chinese whispers:
I would say something very simple, "How is
maths linked to spirituality?" And then he
would translate it into Hindi, it's like kind
of learning about geometric progressions,
five times longer than [chuckles] what I'd
originally said thinking, "strange why it's
so much longer in Hindi?" Then he would reply
taking about 10 minutes to reply and then
the reply being translated to me was about
20 minutes. It was a huge amount of time so
I actually had to go and see him four times
and each time the sessions went on for hours
and I would just say this one question [laughs]
and it would come back and I realized that
I was getting absolutely no answers at all
from this.
And actually to try and get kind of a rational
reason in a sort of spiritual context is completely
the wrong way to go about it. And so I just
started like zoning out and sort of staring
at him. And I learned a little bit about,
he wears the same saffron robes every day.
He eats the same curry every day, it doesn't
have any spices in it to be kind of as bland
as possible. In his room he has no possessions
and what's funny is when you meet him, you
give him gift, but as soon as he gets a gift
he just gives it to someone else. So if you're
lucky to be sitting, there was maybe 100 of
us sitting having an audience with him, gradually
you'd sort of fill up with goodies because
anyone comes and gives something he just gives
them straight back.
And it was just contemplating this that I
realized that he, himself, is sort of embodiment
of zero, of nothingness. It's all about realizing
that Nirvana is a state of nothing, it's nothing
so that having nothing is actually having
something.
And the reason why zero was invented, the
mathematical zero was invented in India, is
that it was a mathematical interpretation
of what was a metaphysical idea.
And I've talked about how we got one, two,
three, and four. The symbol for zero which
comes from India, I mean I used to think as
a kid, "Why zero, zero's sort of nothing,
it's like a hole made with nothing in it."
That's completely to misunderstand the point.
Zero is the eternal cycles of the faces of
heaven, just kind of infinity and also zero.
And it's this sort of spiritual idea linking
infinity and zero and something that's a nothingness
which is why the Indians, India was the culture
where mathematical zero first appeared.
As well as mathematical zero first appearing
in India, this recently appeared. It's the
first zero currency note and I thought it
was absolutely fantastic --
[laughter]
and I don't know if they realize the mathematical
history of India. But the reason why the Zero
Rupee Note was invented, is there's lots of
corruption and so an NGO printed loads of
these notes so that if you want to be bribed
you just give someone Zero Rupee Note like
make a point.
Now our numbers come from India about one
and a half thousand years ago, that's where
the zero's invented in the sort of the system
that became ours. Before that there were numbers,
there were Roman numbers and there's Greek
numbers before then, and Phoenician numbers,
way back to the first numbers. And the first
numbers are about 6,000 to 8,000 years old
and emerged in Sumeria in Sumer which is now
in present day Iraq.
They emerged because people needed ways to
count things without actually just using a
one to one correspondence say with like pebbles
or stones. So just say you were, or notches
on wood. So just say you were a shepherd and
you had 50 sheep. Before numbers, there's
no way of saying you've got 50 sheep apart
from maybe having 50 pebbles in your pocket
or a staff with 50 notches on it. And then
they thought, "Well why don't we make these
little clay pieces," they didn't think this,
this sort of emerged. They're these clay pieces
with different patterns on and each pattern
referred to a different amount. So just say
you had 50 sheep you could make this pattern
say, "Well this is how much I've got." So
it was much easier for keeping track of your
stock and also for doing trade. And that really
--. And those were the first things that you
can call numbers which is a system of words
and symbols for numbers.
And what's interesting, as well as being the
first time that words and symbols were used
for numbers, it's the first of any scripts,
so all literature or any of the Western writing
systems emerged from these first kind of Sumerian
accountants really developing this system.
Now before they had the system, humans would
be able to tell the difference between one
thing and two things it's just that we didn't
have the words, the abstract nouns and the
symbols for one and two.
So what is it that numbers bring us 'cause
most people think, "Well numbers they're so
natural they must have been here sort of forever."
Well now you know 6,000, 7,000 years in the
history of civilization is really not very
much and they are new and it's because they
combine two different things.
[pause]
Anyone who's studied sort of the philosophy
of maths or maths will know all this, but
most people I think are quite surprised they
think that you can't make anything simpler
than a number, it's obvious what it is. First
of all, you can divide it, it has two separate
parts, it has cardinality and ordinality,
those are just the sort of long words for
amount and position.
So the cardinality of the number of chairs
in the front row is gonna be five 'cause there
are five of them there. But when I say, "Count
to ten," one, two, three, four, five, six,
seven, eight, nine, ten I'm not counting things.
So five is literally just what comes in the
position after four and before six.
So I was thinking, "Well how can I bring this
out to sort of explain that it's not obvious,
these are two very different things?" And
then I realized that there are some non-humans
who have been taught to count and they are
chimpanzees and they're in Japan. And so I
called up the travel agent and flew there,
flew to Japan to meet these chimpanzees.
How do you teach a chimpanzee to count? Well
you have to teach the cardinality of a number
and the ordinality of a number.
[pause]
In the early 80s when Japan was sort of pioneering
in touch screen computers they got a chimpanzee
called Ai from West Africa and started to
teach her both the cardinality and the ordinality
using these touch screen computers. And so
it was reward driven: you set a task and if
they get it right they get a bit of food like
shoots down the sides. If they get it wrong
they don't get the food. So they end up only
wanting to do what gets them food so that's
how they work it out.
And so cardinality what would happen they
would show and sort of say different boxes
with say different numbers of carrots or colored
pencils in them and they would have to then
tap the symbol for the digit of how many were
currently referring to that. And also visa
versa, they'd be given a digit say four and
they they'd have a selection of boxes with
different objects in, they'd have to tap the
box which corresponded to number four. Didn't
take very long for Ai to learn how to do that.
Ordinality, what they would do they would
show two digits, say six and seven, so single
digits between one and nine, and the chimpanzee
had to learn to press the lowest one and then
the highest one in order to get the food.
They learned that pretty quick as well.
So in the late '80s you could say that there
was a chimpanzee who had learned the Arabic
numeral system because had a working, functional
knowledge of both cardinality and ordinality.
Then the chief researcher there realized,
[pause]
"We've not taught the chimpanzee zero. Why
don't we teach the chimpanzee the cardinality
of zero and then see if the chimpanzee can
work out what the ordinality is?" So for us
it's just like dead easy, yeah it's below
one, it's less than one, so yeah it's gonna
be zero's before one, one is more than zero.
We get that; it's so obvious to us. So is
it obvious to a chimpanzee? So what they did
first they taught the chimpanzee the cardinality
of zero, when there's a zero there there's
a box with nothing in. When there's a box
with nothing in it's a zero.
And then they did the ordinality test: they
showed two digits of which sometimes one was
a zero and they waited to see which number
the chimpanzee would touch first. Often I
have to hesitate when I say chimpanzee 'cause
I want to say monkey, but a chimpanzee is
not monkeys they're apes and apes and monkey
are very different. And once when I was there
interviewing these people about it I accidentally
referred to one of their chimpanzees as a
monkey and my God [laughs]
[laughter]
it was ugly. [laughs] 'Cause when you work
with chimpanzees, because they're so like
close to us, they're called students and the
lab is called a classroom, it's like kinda
weird, but it's kinda brilliant too.
So they taught the chimpanzee the cardinality
of zero, came to the ordinality,
[pause]
did it a bunch of times and then did the average
amount of times of when the chimpanzee, which
numbers they were and when it was the zero
tapped first, when it was tapped second. And
where was zero?
[pause]
It was between six and seven. So even though
they understood the cardinality of zero they
had no idea about where it was, on the number
line it's less than one. So they did this
test more and more and more and obviously
because they're getting food when they get
it right they're kind of learning and so gradually
the position of zero over the number line
got less and less and less and less but it
never really got below one. It was always,
they were always confused about where the
zero and one were sort of more or less the
same thing.
That I think really shows that what makes
it distinctive for us humans is that we can
slip between cardinality and ordinality very
easily and chimpanzees cannot.
But while they cannot do that --
[pause]
the Primate Research Institute in Kyoto, in
Inuyama but synced to the Kyoto University
had, now they've got about 15 chimpanzees
that can manipulate numbers amazingly well.
And they thought, "Well let's try and use
these skills to see if we can find out anything
else about the cognitive capacities of chimpanzees."
And what they found was that in some cases,
they'd never thought this before, chimpanzees
have a higher cognitive ability than humans
when it comes to the memory of numbers.
So what I'm gonna show you I'm gonna show
you a clip and what's going on here is that
five digits appear on the screen and then
after--
[pause]
when they first did the test for point six
five seconds they're on the screen so you
can see them for point six five seconds then
they become white blocks, white squares.
[pause]
What you've gotta do is remember the order,
the numerical order and to tap them to get
the reward. Now at point six five seconds
humans can do it, chimpanzees can do it.
[pause]
So they did less time, point four five seconds,
then point four three seconds, sorry. Humans
are starting to get confused they can't do
it so well. They can do sort it kind of all
right but it makes no difference to the chimpanzee,
still they get it right most of the time.
Then they went done to what I'm gonna show
you now which is point two one seconds and
now humans really can't do this, but chimpanzees
they can as you can see. Now I think I need
to press play.
So what's going on here that chimpanzee's
here he's gonna press that, that's not a zero
that's the button to start, you're gonna see
five digits for only point two one seconds
and then can you remember their order the
way that the chimpanzee does? And the food's
coming down here which is what's going on.
[pause]
Here hang on.
And the sound isn't --
[sounds of chimpanzee touching screen]
[laughter]
So press the button.
[sounds of chimpanzee touching screen]
[laughter]
It's completely right and it's also interesting
the chimpanzees when they do that they want
to have their heads as close to the screen
as possible, when humans to it you kind of
want to have a bit of distance.
And this was amazing, no one really believed
that chimpanzees could do this and that was
a couple of years ago; point two one seconds,
five digits. They can now do five digits at
zero point zero nine seconds. That's more
than twice as fast or eight digits at point
two one seconds. So completely amazing.
One day,
[pause]
something else happened. They were doing the
same test,
[pause]
which I'll show you now, it's also quite interesting,
the same test.
[pause]
but point two one seconds, he's pressing it
and he'll press it, does it, and then the
chimpanzee hears something and turns round.
So for ten seconds it's not looking; it's
not concentrating; wonders what's going on
?
[pause]
for ten seconds, comes back --
[laughter]
totally gets it right.
Absolutely and then carries on. So not only
do they have this, this way of seeing things
very fast they can remember for at least ten
seconds. And there might be lots of evolutionary
reasons why this is the case that we can't
go into now, but the main point is that there
is something that chimpanzees can do that
are better than us involving numbers, the
memory of numbers.
Now I went all around the world and went out
to Japan to see the chimpanzees. I was probably
the first guy to go on like a maths tour of
Japan. I wanted to see anything to do with
numbers and digits. And I learned that even
though we think that maths is the same all
over the world because one and one is two
everywhere, our approach to maths and the
cultural resonance is very, very different.
And sometimes even the simplest way and I
think it's good to think about this because
it makes us kind of just challenges some of
our own preconceptions about what maths is,
what numbers are, where they come from.
The most obvious one is tallying. I grew up
in the U.K. and you tally like this: one,
two, three, four, five. Obvious, surely the
simplest way, surely they've been doing this
since we were sort of cavemen tallying in
caves and no one does it any other way, but
that's wrong. I don't know if there any South
Americans,
[pause]
in the audience, non-Venezuelan South Americans
'cause Venezuelans do it like this because
the Venezuelans kind of do everything like
America. If you're not a Venezuelan South
American this is how you tally: one, two,
three, four, five which actually is a much,
much better way than the way we do it because
here three and four is always different, you're
never gonna confuse it, whereas as I said
before three and four you would confuse it
'cause at four you have to start counting
the lines. So if you see a bunch of guys in
Brazil playing Dominoes, that's how they're
counting their scores.
In the Far East though in Japan, I see if
there's any Japanese, Chinese, or Korean people
in the audience if you are, be quiet. 'Cause
this is how you tally in these countries:
[pause]
one, any guess where the next one's gonna
come from? From there two, three, four, five.
Is that that really confusing and complicated
and like designed to like turn people off
counting? Actually it's beautiful 'cause what
it means, that is the Kanji character for
correct. So it's almost like a haiku, it's
a way of kind of containing, sort of mixing
words and numbers together and there's something
rather sort of delightful about it. And if
you don't believe me the next time you go
to like a Chinese restaurant or sushi place
in Soho ask for some five beers and the waiter
will mark it like that, it's totally true.
I mean I didn't believe it and I asked myself
a nice little party trick. Whenever you go
to, that's how they tally.
Now --
[pause]
I saw lots of different people in Japan and
one of the most fun people I met with this
guy here, Maki Kaji, and he's the guy who,
I wouldn't say invented he sort of reinvented
Sudoku but probably the most important guy
in the history of Sudoku.
Sudoku was actually invented in the late '70s
by an amateur puzzle maker in America, when
it was a small American puzzle magazine but
in a few Times and no one took any notice.
And then Maki Kaji in the early '80s was trying
to start a Japanese puzzle magazine, saw this
American puzzle magazine, most of it was word
puzzles could understand anything about it,
about those ones. Saw the number puzzle one,
thought it was brilliant.
So he adapted it and now the givens in a Sudoku
are all parallel a bit like in a crosswords
and he coined the phrase, I think he registered
it, Sudoku, which means "the number appears
only once" and then it became a bit of a hit
in Japan and then since it came to Europe
about five years ago and around the rest of
the world. He's become quite wealthy and he
says, "I'm not a mathematician. I'm more of
a numbers impresario; a kind of showman."
And he loves gambling and he was saying, he's
in his 50's he looks a little younger, he
said, "Thank God I didn't make all my money
when I was in my 30's and 40's; I would have
spent it all on Geisha girls," and he's like
the least sort of nerdy numbers guy Japanese
that you'd ever expect to meet.
And what I loved about him is where ever he
saw, when he saw numbers he just was making
games and having fun with them. And this is
what he told me his latest hobby was, taking
pictures of Japanese car number plates. I
don't know if anyone here can maybe see why
he might want to, sort of a good Google question
for [chuckles] These number plates are mathematically
interesting --
[pause]
it's because they're aligned to the times
table, three times five is fifteen and four
times one is four. So actually there are eighty-one
different types of registration license plate
in Japan and he was going around where ever
he saw one the motorway or the car park he
would just take its picture and his idea was
to have an exhibition of the times tables
as seen on car license plates.
[laughter]
I thought that was just sort of brilliant
and you don't need to be a math genius to
appreciate the sort of the beauty and the
simplicity in that.
[pause]
In Japan, probably the greatest way that their
approach to maths and numbers is different
to in the U.K. and in America, certainly,
is in the presence of the abacus. Now this
is an abacus. An abacus is a counting machine
or a calculating machine. It's really the
oldest kind of calculating machine that there
is and virtually all cultures that count have
similar things. Sometimes they don't make
them into mechanical objects they're just
lines and you have sort of say pebbles on
a counter. That's where the word counter comes
from where you'd have little counting things.
And the abacus --
[pause]
a Japanese abacus called the soroban has five
beads per rod so there are ten positions per
rod so they represent the numbers from zero
to nine. It should be horizontal so there's
no, gravity isn't working. And at the top
the bead can either be at the top or the bottom,
black is the bottom. So you start with naught.
These four here would be naught, one, the
bottom goes up; two, the two would go up;
three, three goes up; four, four goes up;
and five they all go down and the top one
goes down to go five. So it's kind of like
a little base five with the base ten there.
Now you do not need, once you get good at
the abacus it's very easy to do additions,
subtraction 'cause just by putting in the
sum you've done the addition already and multiplication
is essentially a little bit more complicated
addition so you can do additions, square roots,
division, all that really, really quickly
using an abacus. And in fact up until the
pocket calculator in Japan and from Russia,
eastwards, actually, everyone would learn
to calculate using an abacus.
And actually I've brought this item on here
which came out ?
[pause]
in Japan in the '70s when the pocket calculator
was becoming popular. And you might think
that this abacus calculator is to, you do
the sum on the abacus and then you just check
whether you're right with a calculator. But
obviously it was completely the other way
around 'cause they didn't trust this so they
would do it here and they would just check
on the abacus just to see if they got it right.
[laughs]
[laughter]
Now the phrase for reading, writing, arithmetic
in Japanese is yonde, kaki, soroban; reading,
writing, soroban. So it's very kind of culturey;
it's something in their culture. And even
though you do not need to use an abacus in
daily life at all, you don't even need to
use it for the school maths syllabus, still
a million Japanese kids every year study the
abacus at about 20,000 abacus schools or kind
of after they're called jukus where it's sort
of after school clubs.
And Japan has this kind of tradition of these
jukus for other things, after school clubs.
Monday you might wanna do violin practice,
Tuesday baseball, Wednesday soroban. And I
went to one to see what they did.
[pause]
And this is basically what goes on in a soroban
school. You learn to calculate using the abacus.
It's very competitive and you can get speeds
and when you get sort of good at it and because
it's competitive the awards that you get are
just like a martial art. So if you get good
you get your Dans and it goes up in Dans,
so just like in karate or whatever, I don't
know anything about martial arts, but I know
that they use Dans, they use Dans in the abacus.
And I went to a competition, 'cause they have
lots of competitions. This is a regional competition,
there were maybe a couple of hundred kids
doing it and it was several hours on their
Sunday. And this is them just, the person's
reading out sums and they're calculating as
fast as possible. This is the sums being read
out and this is what you win, these wonderful
winged figures holding sort of golden soroban,
that's fantastic.
Now why do people learn the soroban? And why
would you want to calculate really fast mentally
if you don't really need to? And I asked this
guy, Yugi Miyamoto, who this is his kind of
group of soroban pupils, why and he just looked
and me and just didn't really understand the
question. And he said, "Well why would you
ever want to run for 26 miles? But people
do." He said, "There's this idea that why
not practice something that the body, the
human can do, as best possible, and running
in sports what about the kind of the brain
muscle as well to kind of practice that."
And also I could see that the kids were really,
they were really having fun. There's something
about learning with the abacus, there's something
kind of visceral about the counting that makes
people enjoy it a lot more.
Now I was kind of fascinated by the soroban
and then Yugi Miyamoto made me more fascinated
by telling me about something called anzan.
Anzan is if you can do the abacus really well
after while you don't need to have a physical
abacus anymore to do the same calculations
'cause you can visualize the abacus in your
brain, right? So I said, "Well what do you
mean?" He said, "Okay," and he got one of
his top pupils and then just said something
it was like I don't know 57 times 221 and
the guy just gave the answer.
And I said, "Well, what's going on in your
brain?" He said, "Yeah, I have like eight
rows, eight columns with the beads in my brain
and I just like moving them around."
[pause]
It's absolutely amazing and Yugi Miyamoto
decided to sort of, 'cause there's something
very Japanese about it, he wanted to kind
of publicize it more. So he thought, "Why
don't I think up a game, some kind of counting
task which the only way of solving it is using
anzan?" So if you were to say 25 times 26
say.
[pause]
Millions of ways you could solve it: you could
stick it in Google for example, you could
go on the beach and a line of 25 and 26 pebbles,
you could us an abacus, you could anzan, you
could do all these things, so it's not good,
that task just saying something.
And then he had this idea, "Why don't I have
a computer screen flashing digits so fast
that you can't write them down and work out
a task like that?" So he invented this game
called Flash Anzan which I'm gonna show you
now which flashes digits incredibly fast and
the idea is in this game here particularly
to add them all up. So what you're gonna see
is 15 digits and they're all three number
digits, three digit numbers, so like 221 is
a three digit number, 15 of them in three
seconds, that's five per second and the purpose
or the object is to count them and say the
answer, to add them all up.
[pause]
Alright.
Fifteen digit, three seconds.
[beeping sounds]
Yep, he got it right.
[laughter]
So what was going on? 'Cause you can't remember
any of the intermediate sums. He's got a blank
abacus, he sees the first one he just sees
it instantly as a shape on the abacus. He
sees the next one and instantly he just adds
it. And he keeps on adding and he's like reading
the printout at the end.
And when I heard about I said, "Oh can I take,
can I film it?" And I filmed it here and I
thought that maybe they would have to do it
10 times to get it right the first time, but
this is the very first time they did it completely
right. So the guys can do it and it's amazing.
Now I was pretty impressed by this but not
as impressed as I was for the next thing that
you can do with an abacus. When I was trying
to understand a little bit about why we can
do this about the sort of neurology of it
or the neuroscience of it, they say in Japan
not that much research has been done on it
but they basically say, "Right brain normal
maths, left brain," no "left brain normal
maths, right brain abacus." What they mean
is that our left side of the brain, the left
hemisphere, tends to be used for linguistic
programming, sort of language, numbers, counting,
all that kind of thing. And the right side
of the brain is the visuospatial skills that
we have. So normally we use the left side
of the brain to do maths but with the abacus
it's using the other side of the brain.
So what this means is that you could do the
abacus or Flash Anzan whilst, either your
left side or right brain is still free so
they designed this test which is to do Flash
Anzan whilst playing a language game at the
same time.
[laughter]
Alright? So what I'm gonna show you now is
it's two 10 year old girls, one of them is
actually the daughter of the teacher. They're
going to be doing I think it's yeah it's 30
digits in 20 seconds and whilst playing this
Japanese word game called Shiritori which
is the first person says Shiritori, the next
person has to say a word that begins with
"ri" the last syllable of the previous word.
And the person after that has to say a word
beginning with the last syllable of the previous
word. Very kind of common, we have things
like that but with less rather than syllables.
So this two girls playing Shiritori whilst
counting.
[beeping sound]
>>girl #1: Shiritori.
[girls speaking in Japanese]
[man speaking in Japanese]
[laughter]
[pause]
>>Alex Bellos: Yeah, they got it completely
right and that was the first time that I filmed
them. It was absolutely fascinating.
So the abacus is basically the oldest way
to calculate, but it's still in some ways
the most versatile and also the littlest understood.
Now very quickly the final section I'm gonna
have to rush through because I realize I'm
running out of time.
I was all these very glamorous places: Japan,
India, Phoenix, Arizona, etcetera but I also
went some less glamorous places: Braintree
in Essex. And I reason I went to Braintree
is that I discovered that Britain's second
largest collection of slide rules is in Braintree.
And as a journalist and having to make all
of sort of this exciting kind of want something
that's quite funny, has a comic potential
and I thought this was going to be hilarious
because the slide rule is gotta be like the
world's, the reputation is like they're the
most nerdy thing ever. So I was intending
to think that it was gonna be easy, easy gags.
But when I got there I realized I kind of
fell in love with mathematical instruments.
Because the slide rule which I guess I'm looking
at the ages of people here, most people here
probably don't even know what a slide rule
is. A slide rule uses logarithms to, you can
do multiplications and divisions, square roots
very easily by sliding two log scales against
each other. And,
[pause]
when the logarithms were invented about 400
years ago.
[pause]
A couple decades later the slide rule was
invented and it totally revolutionized science.
Straight away you could do long complicated
calculations very quickly and probably every
single great invention of the last 350, 400
years required a slide rule. Right up until
you can almost date it it's like August 1974
when Sinclair's pocket calculator came out
and no one needed them anymore. So nothing
has been so dominate and then died so quickly.
And actually I can remember and also from
movies in the sort of '50s and '60s the slide
rule was this sort of really quite boring
like two sticks like really sort of dull people
would have them like in their top pocket.
But actually for hundreds of years there are
sort of beautiful ones were made and every
industry, every trade had their own type of
slide rule.
And when I was sitting at this guy's house
these collections they were gorgeous. This
one is from the 1890's which the log scales,
you pull them out, and that called Thacher's
Calculating Instrument.
This one here was the most amazing. Also in
the 1890's, it's called Professor Fuller's
Calculator and the scales were on a helix
running to about 45 feet. So you could do
a calculation with this two five decimals
places. So normally most slide rules they're
only analog because you're looking on the
stick to see where something goes, you get
about three decimal places. And five decimals
places for most types of engineering is more
than enough. So it's amazing to think that
something could get you, could calculate within
seconds complicated sums of five decimal places
120 years ago.
There's also this the Halden Calculex and
I actually brought on which is a sort of debonair
person's slide rule which you'd have maybe
like this like a kind of pocket watch and
wear the slide rules. The log scales are circular.
And when I was there, I was just getting,
falling in love with these machines and actually
the collection of mathematical instruments
is like a huge growth area. You look an Ebay
there's all these things that are worth hundreds
of pounds is I sought this item here which
looks like a hand grenade or a pepper grinder.
And what it is actually it's not a slide rule
it's the only digital pocket mechanical calculator
ever made.
So Pascal, 400 odd years ago, had this dream
for mechanized calculating and he invented
the Pascaline which is sort of the very first
one. And then Leibniz has its Step Reckoner,
there's this whole history of people mechanizing
counting. That's where the word kind of number
crunching comes from.
And there's the Victorian age and also the
early 20th century around until the mid-20th
century people would have these big desks
sort of machines that would do all this calculating
for them.
Then in the 1930's Curt Herzstark, an Austrian,
had this idea for this new sort of system,
an engineering system, that he can make a
pocket sized one. And it took him 20 years
to work out exactly how to do it and he was
imprisoned for some of that time as a prisoner
in Buchenwald Concentration Camp. And he was
half Jewish so he was going to be killed because
the Germans knew he was working on this. They
didn't kill him and they said, "If you invent
this we will present it to the Fuhrer and
you'll be declared Aryan and you will survive."
And he didn't do it quite in time, we don't
know if he actually did but didn't wanna tell
them, but he'd almost completed it by the
time he was liberated by the Russians.
Then in the years after the war worked out
how to do it, tried to get funding, the only
people who he could get funding was the Duchy
of Liechtenstein. So he moved to Liechtenstein
and for basically up until the late '60s this
was made. And I brought one here which is
the most sort of beautiful, beautiful thing.
[sound of getting item to display]
It basically can do multiplications, divisions,
all those things and you put the number in
and then you grind it round. If anyone wants
to have a look afterwards I'll show it.
But what is sort of interesting is that this
in a sense was the zenith of the dreams of
mechanical calculation. It was pocket-sized
sort of beautiful engineering, beautiful sort
of that end of the road for a way of thought
because then calculators became all about
information and electronics and computers
and you guys and stuff like this. So this
is quite nice it's sort like of a historical
relic and fossil almost of the dreams for
hundreds of years of the mechanization of
calculation.
Now I'm just gonna finish here 'cause at the
beginning of the talk I said and I hope it
will come, "If all numbers were listed alphabetically
what number would come second?"
>>female #1: Eight billion.
>>male #1: [unintelligible]
>>Alex Bellos: Correct. [laughs] Correct.
Or sometimes people, but in French.
>>male #1: [inaudible]
>>Alex Bellos: Cinq billion I think, I think
yes or a billion and eight. Some people they
disagree that it should be one billion and
eight.
So very, post finally, I just wanted to say
that I've been trying, I've got this survey
out to the world, I'm trying to find out what's
the world's favorite number. And I've got
this website which is here, favoritenumber.net,
and so far I've had about 25,000 votes from
numbers from all over the world, from virtually
every country and so please if you do, I'm
trying to just study on the emotional connection
we have to numbers. If you do have a favorite
number or even if you don't go, on there and
say, "Yes I do this is what it is."
[laughter]
Or don't and Tweet it and share it with all
your friends because next year hopefully I'll
have the results.
So that's me and thank you very much for listening.
[applause]
>>commentator: Thank you very much Alex or
maybe I should call you Alexander. I think
we've got just a few minutes for questions
so does anyone have a question for Alex?
[pause]
>>female #2: What is your favorite number?
>>Alex Bellos: Well, that's the whole thing,
I don't have a favorite number and I would
give these talks when my book came out and
people would always put their hands up and
say, "What's your favorite number?" And I
thought they were just winding me up because
it's a really stupid thing to have.
[laughter]
Until I realized that I was in the minority
of not having a favorite number and that's
in a sense what has given me this sort of
impetus because I'm really fascinated by the
fact that people can have favorite numbers
because surely they're all the same. How can
you have this emotional connection to something
which is so impersonal.
>>female #2: But you have a favorite color
don't you?
>>Alex Bellos: Yes but color ?
>>female #2: same idea.
>>Alex Bellos: yes but a color definitely
gives you an emotional reaction like red makes
angry, green is comforting. Why would a number
be more comforting than another?
And then I kind of realized, when I was asking
these questions, people tend to choose numbers
below 20 especially under 10, odds more than
evens which is interesting, and primes more
than non-primes. Now why is this? Lots of
sort of theories and most people the reason
with their favorite number is the day they
were born, right? But only if you were born
on a low prime; if you were born like me on
the 22nd you're very unlikely to choose 22
as a favorite number. So I think that had
I been born on the 7th or the 13th or the
11th that would be my favorite number. [laughs]
This is a lovely discussion and I will come
back and tell you the answers next year. [laughs]
>>male #2: The chimpanzees -- could the chimpanzees
have beaten the humans for physiological reasons
rather than mental capabilities?
>>Alex Bellos: Well what do you mean could
they--
>>male #2: They focus much faster with their
eyes or --
>>Alex Bellos: Yeah I mean the reason why
they can do that is going to be that it's
much more useful in the wild to have those
instant reactions. I mean I'm not sure, is
it an instant reaction a neurological thing
or is it a physiological thing? I don't know
enough about--
>>male #2: both?
>>Alex Bellos: Yeah [laughs] I'm not a neuroscientist
but yeah.
[pause]
>>male #3: Maybe I can ask a question myself.
When you met the guy who had reinvented Sudoku
and--
>>Alex Bellos: Yeah.
>>male #3: and also was the guru of the number
thing, you said he was like least nerdy mathematician
or person interested in maths you'll ever
meet.
>>Alex Bellos: Yeah.
>>male #3: Why do you think it is that there
is this kind of association with maths as
a nerdy pastime interest etcetera within society?
>>Alex Bellos: Well,it is I discovered only
really in cultures like especially Britain
when there is, I don't know we value, we don't
value mathematical skills the way they're
valued in other countries. But even in, say
France and Germany, it's quite common, there
are a lot more women do science even in those
countries. It's something about the kind of
Anglo-Saxon approach I think it's cultural
but I also think it's changing and I think
that whereas before the word "nerd", you'd
never say, "Well, I'm a nerd." That's sort
of a very negative, very pejorative. Now it's,
"Hey I'm a geek." Everyone says, "I'm a geek."
It's quite cool to be a geek. Geeks make lots
and lots of money and do interesting things
--
[laughter]
in a way that they never were seen as doing
that, say, in the 1970s.
[pause]
Yeah.
>>male #4: There's this legend about Gauss
that's using a human calculator to aid him
do you know this ?
>>Alex Bellos: Yes that's true, that's true.
He's called Zacharias Dase and one thing which
is interesting about numbers as well, when
numbers, [clears throat] so these Arabic numbers,
numerals came in about the 13th century to
Europe and it was only, took a few hundred
years for them to become dominant. And when
they were, all of a sudden, some people were
able to have these amazing numerical skills,
the kind of the sort of idiot savant type.
And these people were probably what now we
would call sort of Asberger's cases or sort
strong autistics or whatever. But, yes, there
were some people who had this amazing facility
with numbers and one of them the most famous
one was Zacharias Dase who was employed by
Euler actually it was either Euler or Gauss,
maybe Gauss, where he calculated Pi to 200
places which was the most that was done at
the time. And he did a table of factors up
to about 8 million, it was just unbelievable.
And still now you can get people who are,
have this amazing ability with numbers from
nowhere.
And in fact I'm flying next week to America
and one of the people I'm gonna meet is a
guy who's got Asberger's and he's a taxi driver
from Tucson, but he's the world's best square
rooter. You can give him any number and he
can get the square root; and he just can and
he always has been able to do that. So these
sort of skills which now, he's a cab driver.
If he'd been around in Gauss' day he might
have been working for Gauss [laughs] making
lots of money.
>>male #4: Yeah, I can understand question
about like well Gauss or whoever that was
like he didn't abandon life to start a being
a better calculator. So do you think that
actual pure calculations just like a pointless
hobby like compared to actual life?
>>Alex Bellos: Yeah it's got nothing, there
are very, lots of great mathematicians that
got terrible mental arithmetic and the ability
to be good at mental arithmetic is not really
anything to do with ability to be good at
maths.
Maths values other things, deductive reasoning,
creativity, sort of conceptual things that,
yeah, and in fact CERN were last people where
they've got the Large Hadron Collider were
the last people to use a human calculator.
Up until the '70s a guy called Wim Klein,
a Dutch guy, he was used to do the calculations
that they were needing there and then after
the '70s computers came in and didn't need
it anymore. So there's a kind of tradition
of the human calculator.
[pause]
>>Male Presenter: Okay, we probably have time
for one more question. One more?
[pause]
>>male #5: So you compared the various tallying
techniques and you looked at abacus--
>>Alex Bellos: Yeah.
>>male #5: and things like that--
>>male #5: that's very popular. Are there
any other calculating techniques that are
particularly easy to understand that we should
be teaching our kids instead of the way we
do arithmetic right now?
>>Alex Bellos: The most interesting thing
about how to teach kids, which I hadn't realized,
is also to do in Japan and is about how they
learn the times table. So the times tables
in Japan, and I think in China as well but
I didn't go to China, it's called a kuku 'cause
ku is nine, so it's the nine nines and you
say it exactly as you do here. So we'll start
one one is one, two ones is two, three ones
is three, but they sometimes like a number
in Japanese one can be in it can be ichi,
two things. So the word that you use within
the times tables is chosen to make it scan
better and sometimes the word is actually
changed so ha is eight, ha ha eight eight
is changed to ha pa 'cause it rolls off the
tongue better.
So the children are taught the times tables
as if they are a nursery rhyme with a kind
of musicality to them and they're actually
taught them before they're taught really what
they mean. And this means that one, it's really
fun learning the times tables, it's a bit
like a rap. I went into a school and the kids
love sort almost singing the times tables
and it seems to sink deeper.
So when I was talking to my interpreter and
she was saying, "Yeah, when I have to do say
six times seven I remember the line in the
music of the kuku what six times seven is,
six times seven forty-two and then I say forty-two."
So this idea that language is being used to
make maths easier the sort of marriage between
maths and language is kind of helping the
maths and helping the language, whereas here
they sort of keep themselves to themselves.
[pause]
Yeah.
>>Male Presenter: Cool. Thank you very much
Alex for coming in to talk to us. We have
some -
>>Alex Bellos: Oh fantastic.
>>Male Presenter: little gifts for you.
>>Alex Bellos: Thank you.
>>Male Presenter: I'm sure everyone is very
happy you came in.
[applause]
>>Alex Bellos: Thank you.